[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think there are kind of two approaches
to the question of the nature and
mechanisms supporting consciousness one
is to develop a great grand exotic
theory
and the other
is to take what we think we know about
certain aspects of the phenomenon and
try to make progress on a specific
question
and
many of the papers published now in
neuroscience on consciousness do
precisely that
so the way in really is to ask these
kinds of questions what's the difference
in the brain between when you're in coma
and not when you're under anesthetic and
not when you're in an epileptic seizure
and not and try to
establish what those differences might
be and then build on that so with regard
for example to anesthesia we really do
have a very
significant practical problem and the
practical problem is controlling
excruciating pain
and um
in the old days that is before the mid
19th century people just had to have
amputations root canals tumor
extractions and so forth without any
help
now propofol for example is widely used
in a surgical context
and
so the question we can specifically ask
is what happens in the brain
to
take us from being fully aware and
conscious to being not conscious under
propofol
and if you do it very very slowly
now you know if if you're going in for
an amputation they don't give you
propofol slowly
if you do it very very slowly
and document precisely what happens the
effects are quite interesting
the main effect
at the systematic level
is that we see a decrease in network
connectivity
so that whether when you're fully awake
and conscious things have a pattern of
connectivity throughout cortex and
subcortical structures
that connectivity is disrupted
under propofol
and you have slower and lower and lower
and lower levels of consciousness as a
function of the propofol dopes and you
can track it then also when you come up
at the cellular level what we know is
that
neurons in the brain under propofol
lose 90 percent of their spiking
capacity
so
this is not an explanation of
consciousness but what it is
is an entry point that will allow us to
go further and understand in more detail
what the mechanisms might be